donde me quedé en el último vídeo
hablamos de cómo la hemoglobina en los
glóbulos rojos es lo que absorbe todo el
oxígeno incrementando el gradiente de
difusión o incrementa el incentivo
podríamos decir para que el oxígeno vaya
a través de la membrana sabemos que las
moléculas de oxígeno no saben que hay
menos oxígeno aquí pero si ves el vídeo
de difusión sabrás en qué consiste ese
proceso si hay menos concentración aquí
que hay el oxígeno se difundirá a través
de la membrana y hay menos adentro del
plasma porque la hemoglobina está
absorbiendo todo como una esponja ahora
una pregunta interesante es porque la
hemoglobina incluso tiene que residir
entre los glóbulos rojos porque no están
las proteínas de hemoglobina simplemente
flotando libremente en el plasma de la
sangre pareciera que eso es más
eficiente no tienes que tener moléculas
atravesando
hacia adentro y hacia fuera de estas
membranas de glóbulos rojos no tendrías
que hacer glóbulos rojos cuál es el
punto de tener estos contenedores de
hemoglobina es de hecho una idea muy
interesante si tuvieras a toda la
hemoglobina depositada en el plasma de
tu sangre
de hecho dolería el flujo de la sangre
la sangre se volvería más viscosa o más
espesa y no quiero decir como jarabe
pero se volvería más gruesa de cómo es
ahora y el empacar la hemoglobina dentro
de estos contenedores dentro de los
glóbulos rojos lo que le permite hacer a
la sangre es fluir mucho mejor imagina
si quisieras colocar jarabe en agua si
solo viertes
a
d
directamente en él
wa
qué es lo que sucederá el agua se
volverá un poco espesa un poco más
viscosa y no fluirá también cuál sería
la solución si quisieras transportar
jarabe en agua bueno
podrías poner el jarabe dentro de
pequeños contenedores o dentro de
pequeños
bah
los ríos
y luego dejar que los abalorios fluyeran
en el agua y después el agua no estaría
tan viscosa y eso es exactamente lo que
está pasando dentro de nuestra sangre en
lugar de tener a la hemoglobina dentro
del plasma y hacerla viscosa
está dentro de estos abalorios que
llamamos glóbulos rojos lo que permite
al flujo continuar siendo no viscoso me
ha acercado aquí a los alveolos y a
estos capilares estos capilares
pulmonares
alejémonos un poco o alejémonos mucho
sólo para entender cómo está fluyendo la
sangre y tener un mejor entendimiento de
las arterias pulmonares y venas relativo
a las otras arterias y venas que están
en el cuerpo así que aquí
copie esto de wikipedia este diagrama
del sistema circulatorio humano y aquí
en la parte de atrás puedes ver a los
pulmones déjame hacerlo en un bonito
color obscuro tenemos a nuestros
pulmones aquí puedes ver que el corazón
está justo en el centro y lo que
aprendimos en los últimos pocos vídeos
es que si tenemos nuestros pequeños
alveolos y nuestros pulmones recuerda
llegamos a ellos desde nuestros
bronquios los que están ramificándose de
los bronquios que se ramifican de la
tráquea que se conecta con nuestra
laringe que se conecta con nuestra
fábrica que se conecta con nuestra boca
y nariz pero de todas maneras tenemos a
nuestros pequeños alveolos justo aquí y
luego tenemos a los capilares cuando nos
alejamos del corazón y vamos a indagar
un poco en el corazón en este vídeo
también así que cuando la sangre viaja
alejándose del corazón está de su
oxígeno
es este color azul esto de aquí es
sangre esto de aquí es sangre viajando
lejos del corazón está yendo detrás de
estos dos tubos justo aquí esta es la
sangre alejándose del corazón esto azul
que he estado resaltando justo ahora
estas son las arterias pulmonares luego
continúan dividiéndose en las arterias y
todo lo demás y eventualmente estaremos
en los capilares tubos muy muy pequeños
sigue fluyendo la sangre justo pasando
los alveolos y luego se vuelve oxigenada
y ahora vamos de regreso al corazón
estamos hablando de venas pulmonares así
que volvemos al corazón
estos capilares en los capilares
obtenemos oxígeno ahora volveremos al
corazón espero que puedas ver lo que
estoy haciendo y entraremos al corazón
en este lado de hecho lo puedes ver por
donde estamos entrando al corazón
entraremos al corazón justo aquí
entraré en más detalle en eso ahora
tenemos sangre oxigenada es roja y luego
esta es bombeada al resto del cuerpo
ahora esto es lo interesante cuando
hablamos de arterias pulmonares y venas
recuerda las arterias pulmonares
eran azules mientras nos alejamos del
corazón tenemos sangre de su exige nada
pero es aún una arteria luego mientras
vamos hacia el corazón desde los
pulmones
tenemos una vena pero está oxigenada
déjame escribir eso escribí eso en el
último vídeo
día
sin oxígeno o quizá debería describir de
eso sí
nada
da
y luego la de la pulmonar tiene oxígeno
ese es este pequeño bucle de aquí que
empezamos y continuaré avanzando en el
patrón de circulación porque el corazón
puede volverse un poco confuso
especialmente debido a su naturaleza
tridimensional pero lo que tenemos es
que el corazón bombea la sangre de su
oxigenada del ventrículo derecho
estarás diciendo oye por qué se le llama
ventrículo derecho se ve en el lado
izquierdo del dibujo pero es el lado
derecho de este sujeto cierto este es el
lado derecho de este sujeto y esta es la
mano izquierda de este sujeto esta es su
mano
y esta es su mano
quiero
da
él nos está viendo cierto no nos importa
nuestra derecha o izquierda nos interesa
la derecha y la izquierda de este amigo
y nos está observando tiene globos
oculares y nos está mirando así que este
es su ventrículo derecho
de hecho déjame solo empezar con el
ciclo completo
así que tenemos sangre de su ex y que
nada viniendo del resto del cuerpo
cierto el nombre de este gran tubo es
vena cava inferior inferior porque viene
de abajo de hecho tiene sangre subiendo
de los brazos y la cabeza aquí arriba
ambas se encuentran justo aquí en el
atrio derecho déjame etiquetar eso haré
un gran diagrama del corazón en un
segundo
este es el
a trío
y porque están de shock siguen adam
porque esta es sangre que regresa de
nuestras piernas y estamos corriendo o
regresando de nuestro cerebro esto tuvo
que utilizar a la respiración o quizá
estamos haciendo ejercicio y está
regresando de nuestros bíceps pero es
sangre des oxigenadas aparece aquí
arriba en el atrio derecho está a
nuestra izquierda pero es el lado
derecho de este sujeto del otro derecho
es bombeada hacia adentro del ventrículo
derecho
de hecho fluye pasivamente adentro del
ventrículo derecho los ventrículos hacen
todo el bombeo
luego el ventrículo se contrae y bombea
esta sangre justo
y no lo ves pero fluye atrás de esta
parte de aquí va de aquí a través de
este tubo así que no lo ves haré un
diagrama detallado en un segundo al
interior de la arteria pulmonar nos
alejamos del corazón esto era una vena
cierto
esta es una vena que va hacia el corazón
esto es una vena la vena cava inferior
esta es la vena cava superior estas son
venas stand es oxigenar us después
bombeo esta sangre des oxigenada lejos
del corazón hacia los pulmones ahora
esta sangre de su oxigenada esto es
la arteria cierto esta es la arteria
pulmonar se oxigena y ahora es una vena
pulmonar y una vez que se oxigena
aparece aquí en la izquierda se muestra
aquí en el atrio derecho atrio puedes
imaginar que es como un cuarto con un
tragaluz o que está abierto hacia el
exterior y en ambos casos están entrando
cosas desde arriba no luz solar sino que
entra sangre desde arriba en el atrio
derecho la sangre entra desde arriba y
en el atrio izquierdo la sangre entra y
recuerda el otro izquierdo está en el
lado derecho de nuestro punto de vista
en el otro izquierdo la sangre entra
desde arriba y viene de los pulmones de
las venas pulmonares las venas van al
corazón luego va adentro y entraré en
detalles hacia adentro del
el tri culo izquierdo y luego el
ventrículo izquierdo bombea esa sangre
oxigenada al resto del cuerpo a través
de las arterias no pulmonares así que
todo se bombea hacia afuera déjame
hacerla en un bonito color obscuro no
azul así que se bombea hacia afuera
desde aquí no lo ves aquí el camino está
dibujado es un dibujo un poco raro es
difícil visualizarlo pero lo mostraré
con mayor detalle y luego va al resto
del cuerpo déjame mostrarte los detalles
ahora mismo dijimos que tenemos sangre
de su oxigenada etiquetemos la justo
aquí
esta es la vena cava superior esta es
una vena de la parte superior de nuestro
cuerpo de nuestros brazos y cabeza
esta es la vena cava inferior estas son
más
de nuestro abdomen y de nuestras piernas
y del resto de nuestro cuerpo así que
primero entra al atrio derecho recuerda
lo llamamos atrio derecho porque este es
el corazón de alguien que nos está
observando aunque esto está en el lado
izquierdo entra por aquí es sangre de se
oxigenada viene de venas el cuerpo
utilizo el oxígeno luego aparece en el
ventrículo derecho cierto estas son
válvulas en nuestro corazón y
pasivamente una vez que el ventrículo
derecho bombea y luego libera tiene una
aspiradora y jala más sangre del atrio
derecho vuelve a bombear y luego lo
empuja por aquí ahora esta sangre de
aquí recuerda está aún está de shock
siguen a la sangre de su oxigenada va a
los pulmones para volverse oxigenada
esto de aquí es la arteria
nar
estoy usando la palabra pulmonar porque
va hacia o viene de los pulmones tiene
que ver con los pulmones y se aleja del
corazón es la
seria
pulmonar y ésta
sí sí
nada
y luego va al corazón se frota contra
algunos alvéolos y luego se vuelve
oxigenada y después regresa ahora esto
de aquí regresa justo así aquí vamos
hacia el corazón esta es una de
está en un bucle con los pulmones por lo
que es una vena
no
y tiene contacto con los alveolos y
obtuvo el oxígeno difundido en ella así
que está
y luego fluye a la tro izquierdo ahora
el otro izquierdo nuevamente desde
nuestro punto de vista está del lado
derecho pero del sujeto que nos mira es
el lado izquierdo así que va al atrio
izquierdo ahora en el ventrículo
izquierdo después de que ha bombeado se
expande y esa agua oxigenada fluye al
ventrículo izquierdo luego el ventrículo
izquierdo los ventrículos son los que
hacen todo el bombeo exprime y luego
bombea la sangre a la aorta
esta es una jarra
el día
porque es una arteria porque nos
alejamos del corazón es una arteria
pulmonar no no estamos lidiando con los
pulmones ya lidiamos con los pulmones
cuando fuimos desde el ventrículo
derecho fuimos a los pulmones en un
bucle volviendo al otro izquierdo ahora
estamos en el ventrículo izquierdo
bombeamos a la aorta ahora esto debe de
ir al resto del cuerpo
esta es una arteria una arteria no
pulmonar y está ok sí
la
así que cuando vemos arterias no
pulmonares
estamos oxigenados pero una arteria
pulmonar no tiene oxígeno se está
alejando del corazón para obtener
oxígeno las venas pulmonares vienen de
los pulmones al corazón con oxígeno pero
el resto de las venas van al corazón sin
oxígeno porque quieren ir a ese bucle al
bucle pulmonar justo ahí dejaré esto
aquí espero que esto te dé una idea
ahora volvamos al primer diagrama creo
que tienes una idea de cómo el corazón
está lidiando pero veamos el resto del
cuerpo y únicamente obtengamos un
sentido de las cosas puedes ver esto en
wikipedia si quieres todos estos
diferentes puntos de ramificación tienen
diferentes nombres pero puedes ver justo
aquí que tienes algo parecido a un
ramificado un poco por debajo del
corazón este es de hecho él
celíaco si es que recuerdo correctamente
se refiere a abdomen así que esta sangre
que tu arteria hepática hepática tiene
que ver con él
de tu arteria hepática se ramifica de
esto para dejar fluir la sangre hacia el
hígado también da flujo sanguíneo al
estómago por lo que es muy importante en
la digestión y todo eso y digamos que
este es el tronco hepático tu hígado
está posicionado de esta manera tronco
hepático entrega oxígeno al hígado el
hígado está respirando toma el oxígeno y
libera dióxido de carbono así que se
vuelve des oxigenado y luego fluye de
regreso a la vena cava inferior y quiero
aclarar esto es un bucle es un gran
bucle la sangre no sólo fluye hacia
afuera de un lugar y luego retorna en
otro lugar más éste es sólo un gran
bucle y si quieres saber en cualquier
punto dado en el tiempo dependiendo de
tu tamaño hay aproximadamente
trozos
y lo he buscado toma en promedio al
glóbulo rojo promedio y de un punto en
el sistema circulatorio e ir a través
del sistema completo y regresar 20
2 eso es un promedio porque podrías
imaginar que debería de haber algunos
glóbulos rojos que se quedan atorados en
algún lugar y se tardan un poco más de
tiempo y algunos recorren la ruta
perfecta de hecho los 20 segundos están
muy cercanos a la ruta perfecta nunca lo
he cronometrista dow yo mismo pero es
algo interesante de ver y de pensar en
que está conectado aquí y quienes a
estas arterias aquí arriba que ramifican
estas arterias de aquí desde la aorta
hacia la cabeza y el cuello y las
arterias de los brazos y después bajan y
dejan fluir sangre al resto del cuerpo
así que de todas maneras esta es una
idea bastante interesante en el
siguiente vídeo lo que quiero hacer es
hablar de cómo la hemoglobina sabe
cuándo deshacerse del oxígeno o incluso
mejor dónde deshacerse del oxígeno
porque quizá estoy corriendo y necesite
mucho oxígeno en los capilares alrededor
músculos de las piernas no los necesito
en mis manos necesariamente como
optimiza el cuerpo donde se libera el
oxígeno es de hecho fascinante